a guy who he had like a few really good
jobs and he was really um
i can't remember what it was he was
going to work somewhere anyway and he
was on like a
some kind of web chat and there was a
woman in the middle who was supposed to
be talking to him so he talked about the
nuclear physicist guy yes yes yes and
she hung up the phone on him oh yeah
yeah give me that man any day yeah
because he was ah
this is the thing when wait how how old
are you
yeah that's what i already have to say
yeah go and say it's your choice what
you're talking about i'm 27. so like
before before like you're you're very
pretty right
but i'm saying i'm saying like before
before you had kids you could have
picked that guy i'm sure you had i'm
sure you had men after you left and
right no
no no i did not um
because of the because of the age issues
you started yes one because of the age
one because i was a little bit of ugly
duckling at a point um
and then when i did meet this man it was
like i was already stuck in this
situation so i didn't really date how i
should have but obviously since having
my children and being in this situation
i feel like i've learned so much
that i wouldn't discount the man that
was a nuclear physicist and i understand
why i wouldn't if that makes sense that
doesn't mean that like
i'm saying yeah obviously i'm joking i'm
saying give me that man any day yeah not
necessarily today right but
i feel why not today tomorrow because i
still feel like there's work that i need
to do on myself
um
and i need to be honest with myself
about that i still have children and i
don't want that to be an issue as well
because i don't want to bring a man into
my situation and make them responsible
for my children and it becomes an issue
later on
like i don't want to lay those
expectations on someone so i want to be
at a point where
i'm
i don't i don't want to say independent
but like it would be nice to have
someone but i need to be ready for that
and i need my children to be ready for
that too
i want to put forth the notion that
as a woman that shouldn't be like your
prime
thinking and the reason why i say that
is because
if a high value man like a nuclear
physicist comes along
that's a rare opportunity right you may
never get that again are you willing to
say oh because i'm not ready at this
moment in time i'm going to pass that up
because you won't get this opportunity
like it doesn't come as often and our
value goes down the older we get true i
mean for me if if a high value man came
and he
really saw that potential in me ready or
not
he would show it just like we're saying
that sometimes men decide on
relationships if he was to really show
me look i really want you
because you possess this quality and
this and this and this and
x y and z then it would probably make me
more open to but i wouldn't trust um i
don't trust men that come and be like oh
i want to do this for you and i want to
do that for you and i want to do that
for you because i don't know what your
real intentions are and i need to be
able to like we're saying look at those
red flags vet this person properly
especially because of the fact that i
have trouble i get that because you've
been through a certain situation so okay
i guess all the time as well it's that's
where you've
you that you you you're more patient
with those people 100 percent
you kind of rush into things but you you
take time definitely and within that
time you then get to work out if that
person is what you're saying
going back to the subject so would you
say that the recordings that you have
here
are
and i'm talking to men in general like
would you advise
men to record
if they in a position where someone in
my circumstances
absolutely because as i said it was
wound countless times so it's not a goal
to straight away because beforehand i
tried cancelling i saw there were
certain angles i mean so areas that
may have been issues that i could have
dealt with and again that whole thing
about being a man
so trying to deal with it and that's in
the counseling and speaking to friends
family to try and sort the situation out
but when i could see
how it was getting our hands
and that that control was where that
control was going this is the coercive
control i then said you know what
this is necessary i need to record this
because already i remember i told you
about the
saying about punching in the face
and i'm you can't tell i don't i don't i
advocate i don't hate no woman so don't
ever put me in that position don't never
make me that guy
like don't make me that guy in it so
yeah i have a question do you guys think
that if a girl hits a guy that he can
hit her back
hmm yeah you see i've had a whole
viral tick tock i know guys do it i me
personally
i don't feel that you need to you can
hold them we're physically strong
so you can hold you can you can hold a
woman in it yeah so i don't need to be
hitting back a woman if she's hitting me
because i think if she's hitting you
with objects or using something to
injure you and you have to
then yeah but if it's physical
maybe not why not not if it's
fist and fist no
but if it's like she got a baseball bat
bat and hit you over the head or
something then it might have to be done
why is it considered self-defense when
a man hits a woman and she retaliates
but it's not really considered that if a
woman hits a man because he's physically
pretty strong
yeah but i said in my video we live in a
time where there are no men there are no
women men can be men and women men can
be women and women can be men so what
are you talking about
i think equal rights equal laughs baby
like i mean i'm sorry you had a dude
expect to get hit like you shouldn't i
would never i wouldn't hit a guy i don't
think so i think i don't think most men
want to hit women or choose to hit women
they hit women because they have no
choice yeah and now there are some men
there are some
i wouldn't go that far
you know i'm not saying every single guy
but in the situation i don't feel that
you know if there's a altercation men
the first thing they do
is think oh i wanna hear what i'm gonna
hit this woman it's usually when no i i
don't i agree i don't know sorry i keep
going
no i i agree with you i don't think
that's their initial like reaction
but i just i think as women we need to
be more accountable if you are if you
are hitting a man expect to get hit
there's a it's a difference if he hits
you first okay that's that's
self-defense but if you are decking a
man and like literally try and with the
intention to hurt him
and it doesn't even matter your intent
if you're hitting a guy like expect to
get hit you shouldn't be doing that
women they think is cute that's why
actually that was my man image actually
given challenge because i know there are
men that do that you know that they all
got that behavior of control that you
know so i think that's why i had to sort
of say that but in terms of as pearl's
saying the the woman that wants to hit
men those women that want to put their
hand on men you know what i mean so
it doesn't have to be that kind of you
know we're not we're not in a boxing
ring i'd say this [ __ ] yeah
do you know generally that you're
physically stronger than a woman
yep yeah
it's just how you know that ish do you
generally know that you're physically
stronger than women yes
women do you generally know that
physically stronger than you yes
right so if you know that
if you know that if you put your hands
on a man that's up to you
because i know that mike tyson's
physically stronger than me right right
and i'm not going to go with mike tyson
that's so true like if you if you went
up to the rock and you hit him and you
got hit back no one would feel bad for
you
bro just like if a girl that was weaker
than me came up to me like i'm pretty
tall i'm pretty strong if she came up to
me hit me and i hit her back no one
would feel bad for like forever can i
put something into perspective
do we all acknowledge that emotional
abuse exists
of course it does so you acknowledge
that a man can be
emotionally abusive to a woman right yes
of course this man
is
continuously
emotionally abusing the woman and we've
established that women are more
emotional than men men are more physical
than women right
so if the woman is more emotional and he
is abusing her emotionally
but he is physical and she reacts in a
physical manner
why is it so confusing because we know
that we get now but we get that boy
there's context
so the point is what i'm trying to say
is imagine like a woman has been
emotionally abused for years and years
and years and years and she's had enough
eventually she might decide to pick up
that baseball bat and deck him again i
don't think does that mean it's not an
excuse that's not an excuse
no but everyone does have a snack
everyone does have a snapping point i
get that everyone's got a breaking point
just said that's still not no that's
that's not an excuse so i'm saying let's
leave the situation like there's no
excuse for that if you if a girl does
that expect to get hit back yeah but you
there's feel like there's no excuse you
can't say that a man is physically
stronger than a woman okay let's flip it
let's flip it if a woman's emotionally
abusing a man and then he he freaks out
one day and decks her is that cool
because because you just excused it for
the woman is it cool
no you're right yeah okay
i was interested because you got money
you got money trained
this is what i mean like we have this
society we always make excuses for women
but that's the thing though this is the
thing the double standards exist though
but i think the double standard is
because
it's because obviously a man is seen as
more physical so if he does flip out
like when you actually put into context
it's the same thing so if we're looking
at equality then it should be looked at
exactly the same in the court isn't that
what you want it doesn't know what women
ask for equality
what it means i'm just saying in general
would it be the same if a
trans woman hit
a regular woman
would that be would you consider that
the same please
wait
um
i feel like
it's literally what happened
they in my opinion i didn't watch the
thing but from what i saw online i feel
like they were both abusive towards each
other they were both taking drugs
together they were both doing things to
each other and for whatever reason
it's come out yes she probably did she
she did she lied she said whatever they
said
but then at the same time there was
videos of him acting wild and mad and
doing whatever but he would have never
gone to the police with it what the
difference is that she went to guys as
what pearl's been saying she knew that
she as a woman she could go and be
believed he's only done that in defense
other than that the yes they would have
people have toxic problems and as a
matter of fact that's one of the
recordings she said go you go tell them
johnny depp that you a man has been
abused they won't believe you um
so this is it so this is the and that is
one of the things that
let's flip it what if what if a man said
oh go to the police they won't believe
you would you would you believe it was
would you believe that it was mutual
like they were both hitting each other
if there's a man recording saying that
that's my experience
the
exactly what you just described it just
happened he literally he felt right
right so should because it's the same
thing should we just automatically
assume you guys were abusing each other
um
i don't want to assume i don't want to
say you should assume that we were
abusing each other but when you look at
the actual complexity of the situation
right abuse started from somewhere
so you have to kind of like understand
the root of it and it's not to like
excuse any type of abuse towards each
other
but
not to make it personal i'm not meaning
to make it personal guys but if a 16
year old girl
and a guy that is eight years older
and then he's continued doing whatever
he's doing for x amount of years
eventually she's gonna defend herself i
understand that so it's like
it's difficult to say like i said i
admitted everything that i did
when i was even in the whole thing
the police told me
don't add that in there
don't say that
so when you're talking about the book of
how to destroy a man it's as if they
were trying to make me destroy him when
i was simply telling the truth and the
plain truth i missed that you said that
they said this is why we call it the
gray area because would you say they
said don't they told me
not and it was a female officer as well
because she knows how the system works
actually she understands that if you
allow them to have any leverage over you
in the court of law that the other
opposition will use that leverage
against you and manipulate in such a way
that it will kind of excuse the behavior
that he was doing towards you which
means the truth is not the truth but if
you want to really look at the situation
he was abusing me from the beginning as
a 16 year old girl
knowing that i was homeless
so at the end of the day it's like
you're using that my risk my reactions
and my responses to excuse his behavior
which makes me think that
it just feels like you can't get
anywhere in the world telling the truth
it's not that because obviously is
the problem is when when they made the
justice system it's either guilty or
until proven innocent or innocent until
proven guilty
and even in amber heard johnny depp
she's not going to jail she got sued
yeah also i wanted to say did she not
also collect a bag from him that she was
supposed to give to charity and she
didn't yeah yeah yeah she could yeah
but it's it's just like that's the
system if you don't have enough evidence
like there's not much you can do
because even even amber heard she's
walking free she's just broke